hi everybody it's nice to be in person
again I've like given lots of talks in
my living room to zoom now there's like
people who laugh and Heckle got some
good heckling Paul ah there we go look
at that interactivity so uh are you
gonna talk about desk talked about Das
for a long time
they talk about deploying that which is
like the least fun part of desk get get
prepared and it's motivated by this
conversation and I have a lot these days
so I wear two hats I maintain desks I
also helped to work in a company it's
not that's all coiled and my
conversations look like this I say to
you all use desk it's easy it's fun and
then you say
I love jazz go Dash that's what you all
say all the time
uh I then say try coiled it's easy it's
cheap and you say oh this myself even
cheaper and that's just not that's just
not how companies work um so I need to
convince you that it's actually not that
easy to deploy a desk and this is what
that talk is so most of this talk I'm
gonna be sort of is my normal open
source hat on I'm gonna be mostly
focusing on this it is actually not that
easy to deploy anything especially not a
distributed computing system especially
not in Python wherever it is you work in
your company
that's most of the topic of this talk
this talk this is an iceberg problem
right this is it seems really easy at
first it's just borrowing a bunch of
machines from the cloud from kubernetes
from your HPC machine
a lot of crap underneath that Iceberg
and so a lot of people like go into the
saying yep I think it's done in a week
it actually takes about a year so this
is a classic Iceberg problem it's mostly
talk to me really want to be me talking
about the bottom of that Iceberg to
convince you that it's a challenge uh
and then we'll talk about some solutions
that exist I'll mention the one I get
paid for but also some others that exist
in ecosystem just to talk so again in
this talk we will see first part a desk
example because I find that if I show
you a dashboard with pretty lights I get
the attention for the rest of the talk
uh then we'll talk about sort of that
Iceberg we'll learn more about the
problem uh and then we'll talk about
some solutions that exist if I have time
I've got to set a timer
is going
to clock there
um yeah so let's start off with the task
example
I also have like 100 slides here this is
new content for me so we're gonna see
how this works
so this example oops no that's not what
I wanted
I like it so far thanks Paul appreciate
it excellent work heckling I've asked
Paul the Heckle throughout the
conversation by the way uh because again
Zoom was was hard for all of us
[Music]
yeah that's great so
um
last week I had a conversation actually
had many conversations where people
wanted to use xgboost and Hyper
parameter optimization I had like three
in the same week it was strange so
here's an issue
and I also had a conversation with Mike
McCarty at Nvidia old collaborator he's
like yeah we've been working on this
problem too we're using XG boosts on
gpus with this Library called optuna
optune is a hyper product auction
framework that's pretty new not pretty
new it's pretty great I should say it's
easy to use super flexible and so Mike
was using it with uh so he's got some
extra boost code here I don't understand
he's got some pop tuna code down here I
also don't understand and then in here
he uses Das to like use optuna many
times
so it's cool good example of using task
and actually boosting up tuna all
together
I wanted to try this out one challenge
one common wart that we see with people
using extra boost and all tuna together
is that you need to set up a database
so the very none of this matters the
rest of the talk just an example
but in this type of database so the top
of this notebook Mike's colleague is
installing MySQL and that just seems
like a wart and it's my job as a source
maintainer to make software that's a
little bit smoother to use I want to
remove this need to have to set up a
mySQL database in order to use these
tools together
fortunately my other colleague James
bourbeau has a pull request that does
exactly this he's a pull request to op
tuna that adds Das support to make it
easy uh to do all that coordination work
you only need a database cool I want to
try it out we're going to go and try
that out together
and so I sometime last week I
installed
uh James's work so I like checked out
optuna also the secret to this demo is a
Das demo but secretly there's a lot of
deployment speed bumps we're gonna run
into they were really smooth we're going
to see those same speed bumps throughout
the rest of the talk we're hitting the
first one here
so I needed to install
um some software that my colleague James
had written on my machine and I
downloaded it from git I installed it it
was good
I'm now asking for a cluster and that's
coming up
so what's happened here I've taken my
local software and I've kind of like
sent it up to the cloud somewhere
I've then provisioned 20 machines that's
me asking in this case Amazon web
services give you 20 machines please and
Amazon sort of finds those machines for
me
now it's in the booting instance phase
all those 20 machines are booting up
they're turning on their operating
systems are being loaded they're
connecting to the local disk they're
connecting to the network around them
and they've all switched now they've all
started launching their software
environments they're launching the same
version of python I have locally they're
launching installing desk I actually
have like developed versions of tasks on
my laptop they're installing those
versions of like edited things or
installing those
they're installing XG boost they're
installing up tuna all the libraries
that I need in order to run my
experiment awesome
and they're going to do this for about a
minute so I need to find something
interesting to talk to you for about a
minute
um
Paul
oh there's another one
make the font bigger Natty says
excellent job Nettie
um and now they're coming up they're
getting ready cool so these machines are
now at my best I have borrowed these
machines from the cloud and set them up
I'm ready to go
I'm going to connect up to my Das
dashboard
which of course you all love this is why
we're here to hypnotize you
and I'm going to use this this is the
new line that James added this task
storage this is what we're testing to
see if this actually works
we're going to run uh Mike's same code I
turned off gpus sorry Nvidia
um yeah now it's gonna work so now we're
like training lunch at 5G boost models
using opt tuna lots of machines that are
mentioned in the cloud a couple of
minutes ago right this is like the thing
that we all want to do this is an easy
Pleasant smooth experience how easy you
can get it done in a week I'm sure
um uh and so this is going to finish in
about a minute
we're gonna like wait a little bit look
at the flashy lights
and what's neat this actually is kind of
taking a little bit long I'm wondering
why this is slow this maybe should be a
little bit faster let's dig into that in
a second
first we can see some results I don't
understand these results but like maybe
if you're a machine learning person you
do and you can like get engaged in them
cool like some of these parameters are
more important than others is what I've
learned
wait this is slow this this felt slow to
me it should have been faster we can
pull up some profiling information and
if you're like familiar with that you
know how to interpret these plots if
you're everybody else you don't what we
learn is that this little bit right here
this part of the flame graph is three
percent this is actually training the
machine learning model and this 97 is
all overhead
and so there's something wrong with
James's code how awesome is it that I
was able to experiment with this and
actually I sent James an email James is
actually on PTO last week his like nanny
quit you do some some like child care
but I sent him an email anyway because
I'm That Kind of Boss
um I said like look something's weird uh
here's a performance report
like you can go and look at the sort of
the workflow that I just did and you can
see the same thing that I just did
I then like wasn't done so 30 minutes
later I kind of experimented around and
like put a print State into your code
and this function and it printed out
thousands of times that kind of code
should not have run you can go and
download logs here and so I can download
some logs James can go download some
logs is on my team and he can go and
scroll down over here to the very bottom
and like
this is all the crap that shouldn't be
there so again this is showing you that
things are broken which is the common
state of the world the world is broken
far more often than it is correct
and it's our job to rapidly unbreak the
world as a team so what I've just shown
you is what I did last week to try to
unbreak the world a little bit so I'm
going to switch back to slides we're
going to refer back to that example a
few times but we'll see a few of the
things that I'm going to talk about in
that example
so now part two of The Talk learn about
the problem right now to go to the
iceberg and look at what's underneath
the iceberg how about borrowing machines
kind of the top of the iceberg we're
going to talk about installing software
network access observability and user
and cost management these are things
that I see the most often you might see
totally different things the iceberg is
huge there are lots of icebergs this is
my version of the iceberg
so first borrowing machines
I got 20 machines from Amazon in a
couple of minutes cool how did I do that
I can do that from lots of different
systems
so when you borrow machines you usually
say I want 50 machines they've got to
have 12 CPUs each and 100 gigabytes of
RAM
right and you then send that little
message off to whatever system it is
that you have in your company that
borrows machines to lends machines to
you
uh this might be something like
kubernetes on the right we've got
kubernetes a task operator spec
might also be some weird Cloud API this
is the Amazon ec2 fleets API which we
use internally the coils
it might also be uh you know some HPC
job scheduler batch script but in
general all these cases
you know Das provides apis that
translate I want this many machines as
many CPUs as much memory to whatever the
underlying system that manages your
machines and lends them to you that does
that
we're actually pretty great at this I
think we're only system that does this
to like every possible system you can
think of uh no matter what system you
have Das can run out system
if you have a system that doesn't run on
that isn't like only use inside of your
organization I will buy you a beer
um
as an example here are some projects
that possibly cover what you want to do
for like old Hadoop systems yarn mesos
if you're in that decade
um all of the clouds sorry myself that
business was great everyone loved mesos
it just like didn't whatever I don't
know cluttered and it adopted
digital ocean hetzner you know Hester
existed uh every HPC job scheduler SSH
if you're into that NPI like they're
asking to play on that thing
but this is just the tip of the iceberg
right this is just borrowing machines
but even this is pretty complicated
right like it's not just CPUs and memory
and disk it's can I have fast disk can I
have gpus you can actually have like the
cheap kind of GPU or the expensive GPU
or the thing that Nvidia has only said
this whole sold 10 of
uh can I have spot pricing in this
region but actually a spread across as
many availability zones as possible
because like some zones have more spot
than others it gets really complicated
really quickly if you have users who are
somewhat sophisticated these things
actually make like
a significant difference in your cost
overall there's like very fine
differences you can do that have very
strong effects in what you're running
with
many people go to the kubernetes route
my experience that kubernetes is great
for like this small medium large case
but I guess kind of weird when you start
to try to model out all the different
options you might consider
um so you can but it's like tricky
so that's like part one that's the tip
of the iceberg I'm gonna go into other
deeper things
also just to harken back a little bit to
the notebook
let's go back over here we saw me asking
for machines here and I wanted 20
workers now two CPUs each I actually
specified also the things like spot and
Spot On Demand fallback because I heard
a little bit about price so this is me
specifying the recipe that's kind of
what we saw in the example
keeper and the iceberg the second
problem people run into is installing
software
this is like very painful often
um so what does that mean on my local
machine I had jupyter notebook running
on this laptop I like asked much
machines on the cloud
I had some software on my local machine
I needed to get that software out onto
some wire then out onto all of my Das
workers
something needs to provide that process
this depends this varies strongly based
on where you are
uh and actually there's a lot of
different parts of this
you need to have it from the very top
you've got like the base lever operating
system
evolves very slowly
at the bottom you've got things that
evolve very quickly like the individual
python functions that you're running and
there's a lot of stuff in between
now we often think about our software as
being condo packages and pip packages
and that's true but it gets weird
sometimes you've got
private packages sometimes you got
things in private GitHub sometimes you
things have things that are locally
editable sometimes things that aren't
condom package or system packages so now
you have little Python scripts and if
you're supporting users of any variety
you're going to read do all of these
things
there are a couple of interesting
projects I'm going to point out here
which try to solve this problem to be
particular that's conda store from a
nice Folks at quantstock a Quant site
apologies
um Echo come on Paul oh God
nothing yeah coincide
um and prefix which actually came out of
contact aha that's why I said that
um prefix is a new company made by the
mama developers running people check
them out it's a really cool really cool
developer group
uh so if you're on HPC system this is
all handled through a network file
system
so if you have a computer that was built
like more than a decade ago you're
actually totally fine like NFS systems
are beautiful they handle all this
perfectly it is Magic
like I know this is oh I I hearken back
or if I see someone who's like working
like an old research scientific lab I'm
like yes you do not have this problem it
is all handled for you by some beautiful
Network file system software
if everybody else you probably use
Docker which is like it's a small amount
of magic right
um this works Dockers great it's an
amazing technology you can like build a
Docker file locally it'll work remotely
irregardless of the platform
um it sometimes sucks to like edit your
Docker file to install a package and
then like Mount your local like
directory you're working from into the
docker image to then like push out and
you've got to do a build and a push
um that's that's a bit challenging
uh Docker was built for stability in
mind and a lot of other folks actually
really value dynamism and there's a kind
of a tension here between these two
things uh we saw this in my notebook
right like I
I installed some stuff from git into my
local machine I then like edited that
code and added a print statement
I then asked for a cluster and
everything came up right like my system
saw I had locally edited packages it
built wheels for me it shipped those
Wheels out to my workers
this is the kind of dynamism that
actually really helps to accelerate work
especially if you want to sort of work
with something that's
that's broken which all of our software
is
uh so uh we have these different Stacks
most it groups think of this problem as
just sort of the top of this stack
I'm going to take some condom packages
and make some Docker images you know
we'll be good
uh these are also really important
especially if you have sort of like data
science teams trying new things I
encourage you at least like be aware
that this problem exists
uh this is still a super open problem
the like thing I showed you in coil is
also super broken like this is a wild
west problem uh this is not solved so
moving on point number three we've
talked about barring machines we talked
about installing software we're talking
about network access this is really
boring uh also probably not important to
most folks unless you care about
security which you maybe should but not
for a while
so uh task as a scheduler it's got some
workers you got your local machine you
connect to that machine probably with a
command like this you say client you
give it the address of the scheduler you
go ahead if you do this today and
there's a TCP in front of that protocol
and that connection is not secure
so it is unsecure someone else can go
and connect that same scheduler I have
never in like eight years of my life
working on desk ever seen this happen
there aren't people like trolling the
internet looking for task schedulers but
they could and your it Department cares
about this uh and so there's like
various solutions to this the best
solution to an open source is probably
dasc Gateway which like hands
security keys to all the players in a
nice way so they can talk to each other
either through the Das Gateway or
independently it can it can sort of
broker conversations rather than proxy
them to ask Gateway is great recommend
trying it out
um this requires also that you have like
some other system allows everyone to
trust Das Gateway there's like a there's
a there's a continuous flow of trust
that needs to happen here there's some
sort of auth system that needs to exist
and this allows for you know us to talk
to our desk clusters but not some other
user talking to our scheduler or some
other worker trying to like sneak into
the desk cluster to siphon off some some
data or some other Das Gateway trying to
master it as a dash Gateway that we
connect to and Trust right there's like
lots of ways in which this can go bad
this is all connected to your user
database which you'll need to hook into
if you're doing like the pure open
source route you're probably like
installing jupyter Hub or something we
see a lot of people using Das Gateway
and Jupiter Hub deployed somewhere with
a DNS record and that like seems to work
out okay you can get that to work you
care about security you need at least
that
if you like working on it Department
place you have other solutions to this
but something you need to think about
um you I like
people use security as like a scare
mongering tactic I genuinely think that
most people don't need this
you can get pretty far not caring about
this you shouldn't
you like should protect your data
but many people don't and they're okay
you should like try to ask without
caring about this too much and then you
should care about it then you should
cancel it
everyone who's like running companies is
laughing in the crowd
am I wrong Joe
uh okay yeah okay Point number four
observability
so stuff broke what happened uh we saw
this right I like told James stuff broke
I signed him a thing this thing may be
slow I had to communicate to him what
was broken and I sent him things that he
could look at I after the fact
after Das was done running he could
still look at see historically what had
happened and what was broken and that
was really critical to us fixing the
problem it's worth noting that we fixed
the problem right like we've been
engaging with the Altoona folks and as
of nine hours ago they're in Japan
they're asleep now like they're pretty
happy with how things are going
so like we've been able to resolve a lot
of these issues because we have all
these tools around us that allows us to
move quickly
so stuff broke what happened
observability I just did that uh thanks
sleds
um I'll talk about a few different
things Vlogs logs is the easiest thing
you should have logs stored somewhere uh
commonly people say my Dash broke I get
this all the time I want to ask what
happened
right another common uh case you know
this conversation happened two weeks ago
with a major customer of ours I said
like look you have a lot of it you have
a lot of issues we've fixed a lot of
those issues actually had this
conversation just earlier today
um like looking at a group of people
yeah
you should upgrade like we've already
fixed everything that's broken
um but current workflows might break
this is a super serious problem like
well you should have like a development
version and a prod version you switch
back and forth between them that'd be
good they don't have that unfortunately
not the folks in the room but like other
folks the generic folks and so I'm like
great okay so if you don't have
Dev and prod like let's assess all of
your active workloads let's see what's
going on and we can make a judgment call
right we shouldn't leave things broken
for some users who need this upgrade
because we're breaking other users we
should make a
a well-informed judgment
so let's assess everything and say how
would we do that
they have like no visibility into how
things are actually running
uh and that's actually really tricky
they actually cannot move forward
without that observability so they can't
make decisions right Telemetry informs
decision making and this is really
important this is what you need sort of
the bottom of the iceberg
uh fortunately Das provides a
a very large amount of telemetries
searching through the right word that
was like a little bit swear wordy but
not too much decided with really large
that's provides a lot of a lot of
telemetry
the very basic thing is logs to ask it's
a process it dumps logs the standard out
standard error you should put those logs
as an aggregation service
the cloud watch it might be data dog you
should then also sound silly but like
make it easy for your users to access
those logs surprisingly surprisingly
uncommon
um
that's also like if you use it as
dashboard you know the task tracks
a ton of information like we actually
have to track this information in order
to do our jobs of scheduling your
workload we know every line of code that
you've run how long it's taken we know
every transfer that you've done we know
every line of code you've like submitted
uh we know every file that you've
touched like there's a ton of
information inside of task if we can
capture it it's too much information to
save all of it
it's ephemerally visible in the Das
dashboard but we can save some parts of
it and that's actually I think elect a
big space for opportunities especially
as large organizations try to optimize
across the organization
a very simple way of doing that this is
like not my favorite way but it's a good
way uh is Prometheus Prometheus is a
very standard technology for
observability and telemetry
Prometheus metrics for years
you probably have some system in your
organization that is tracking Prometheus
metrics
pointed a task uh and you can like get
lots of interesting things coming out of
it
it's not as good as a dashboard but it's
it's useful we've actually had coiled
found a lot of
very interesting performance
improvements that we've been able to
achieve by using this
uh great so which saves lives
okay uh using cost I'm gonna move yeah
we're working on time
so uh using cost or I think the the most
common way this occurs is that I shut
everything down
and am I really really sure about that
uh actually wait a minute
going back to my my notebook like I
never close this I am still wasting
money at the bottom of this I had this
cluster closed thing I should probably
go press that it's okay I burned like a
buck right that's not a big issue what's
it is an issue if I leave it on for like
three weeks and then it comes as like
hey dude do you still need these
instances right can I ask like show of
hands who's had that experience
yeah like a lot of us have had that
experience right
coiled actually would have like cleaned
this up after 20 minutes of me not
touching it so like I've learned to just
like not actually care which is which is
nice
uh Jacob Tomlinson the like probably
deployment Czar in the Das Community
thinks this is the the scariest problem
we have today it's very hard to actually
try something in the cloud because
you're afraid you're not going to clean
it up
and that's that's challenging
so
um this is that like this is the
question
so
um I'm not going to show some images
here so
you should be able to answer these kinds
of questions right how much money am I
spending over time what actually is
occurring broadly
you probably want to attribute that to
various people right who in my group is
spending time at which point
are they using things efficiently or
they're like turning on GPU clusters and
not using them
you probably want to like limit their
ability to spend money right these are
all things you probably want to do
um not at the start this is like an
iceberg problem like when you're a
little bit deeper on you'll care about
these things not when you're getting
started
okay so I scared you with the iceberg
there's like way more of the iceberg to
talk about but I've got seven minutes
left so I'm not gonna talk about any
more
instead of talking about Solutions I'm
gonna go through a few I'm gonna talk
about mostly two or three uh talk about
nabari uh previously called qhub I'm
going to talk briefly about Saturn and
about kubeflow I asked for slides from
all of those people who were sort of
active uh the Barney slides were the
best we're gonna spend the most time on
the Bari uh it'll talk about a little
bit about coiled
so
um yeah these things there are also some
big companies have to ask Solutions or
like to ask parts of their Solutions I
have yet to find someone who uses them
and likes them but they exist so if
you're on IBM or gcp or Azure ml you
could also try out their desk thing but
I recommend actually
other folks instead so qhub it's been
around for a long time it comes from
quantite it was renamed to nabare uh
it's great uh it is a bunch of tools
Jupiter Hub prefect Argo dasc Honda
condo store
jitsi video chat I hadn't heard of
before but there's a lot of tools that
are all bundled together and you can use
them as a platform
it also has desks which is why I'm
talking about it
um nibari it's really hard to deploy
this stuff uh Navarro's infrastructure
as code or git Ops if you're familiar
with that sort of concept
you have a yaml file you specify a bunch
of things they turn that yaml file into
terraform which then gets deployed to
your cloud of choice or an on-prem
version it'll kind of work on HPC
sometimes
and that turns into a running uh running
deployment
nabari is doing a tutorial on Friday at
I think 11 A.M I recommend going to them
it's a cool platform
I've got a lot to do to have a good time
with it recommend checking it out
I mentioned a few of their things so
there's many tools in the bar I
mentioned a few one is condo store condo
store attempts to solve the installing
software problem
so you specify a condo environment the
requirements file and make stock images
for you those became available to tasks
those become available to Jupiter hub
uh some people don't want to code in
Jupiter it's nice to have a system that
you can write in other ways so nabari
will support supports things like vs
code you can use like an actual IDE and
Jupiter that's nice to have that
flexibility
and then things like dashboard
deployment model deployment there's lots
of things like another
so there's Saturn Cloud Saturn cloud is
very much like nibari it is a set of
tooling that all kind of works together
there are more AWS focused uh in in
defense so I'm actually going to slip
skip through these things let's just
says the various slides were better and
Saturn and more are kind of similar I
gave Hugo she the like
owner of Saturn relatively little time
to make slides for me so I apologize you
go for skipping past some of this stuff
but Saturn is very AWS native you can
like go to the marketplace you get a
button you have Saturn running in your
system so that's that's neat about it
um moving on kubeflow kind of the same
thing uh but instead of being AWS
focused it is kubernetes focused right
they've got a big set of tools that they
find are really commonly used in ml just
like nabari has a set of tools they find
really commonly used in data stuff
um
kubernetes has like a whole Jungle of
tooling to solve all the problems I
mentioned
it's hard to find the right tools and so
keyflow is like an opinionated set of
those tools you can install
they're very kubernetes forward recently
actually there's a Blog published today
by Jacob Tomlinson Das developed a dasc
operator which is like a much more
native way of using dascon kubernetes
using document kubernetes today I
recommend checking out the blog I think
it was tweeted from the Das Dev Twitter
account this morning
oh but let's get past this okay coiled I
got three minutes from my performance
hat you have a for profit hat for me yes
one second yes yeah come on throw it
over
I'm now taking off my open source hat
I'm putting on my for-profit hat
okay so I'm gonna steal nabari slides
right so nabari has all these things
you know Saturn has a different set of
things when they keep the same slide
Cube flow same thing coiled not so much
right coiled is mostly just dust in the
cloud we do far far less for you we only
do desks but we do it really well
what we actually really care about
though is about working outside other
things
coil does not provide notebooks but I
from my laptop connected to coiled
right like this is not a coiled notebook
this is on my machine I like typed in
Jupiter lab on my machine and then
imported coil and made a coil cluster
right so we try very hard to run
anywhere that python is run we look at
that space we create as similar space as
we can in the cloud and we connect you
to that system smoothly
so if you want to use coiled from like
GitHub actions it's trivial if you want
to use coil from prefect it's trivial if
you want to use coiled from our studio
it's trivial if it runs python anywhere
you can run python you can run coiled
um so we you can run vs code I run it
from Vim I run it for my python uh Cloud
just focuses just on desk we try not to
provide a platform we try to provide
task as well as possible that allows us
to really really focus on making the Das
experience smooth
so there are like
50 different things I could talk about
about little small paper cuts that we
solve I'm going to focus on three
one set up two software three costs
these may be like the biggest pain
points that we hear in order
so setup if you have a laptop and you
have AWS credentials you can do this and
you'll have a Das cluster running so uh
you can authenticate with GitHub Google
or passwords you can like log in in the
next 10 seconds
uh you can deploy so coil deploys in
your Cloud we do not manage computation
for you instead we manage your cloud
account on your behalf you give us
enough permissions to like press all the
buttons in your cloud account and we
press those buttons just right
um I don't know how I like never log an
AWS console I use like a config file
locally
um I'm just gonna like LS
like if you have this you can ask coil
to manage your cloud account and this
works about with about 70 of credentials
that we found about 7 people who try
running coiled set of AWS looks at their
credentials sets everything up takes a
few minutes
you can trust us a little bit not too
much we don't look at your data we just
like set things up for you
and then yeah where you run Python and
we're super configurable right so like
you have machines you can have like lots
of weird crazy configurations
you can ask for anything you want from
the cloud and we set that up smoothly
for you
you also like support other colleagues
who don't have those credentials there's
a whole team management system I won't
talk about at all so that's setup and
composability is easy to use from
anywhere it's pretty easy to get started
I think it's the easiest platform to get
started with but we'll let you make that
judgment
to software we saw this earlier so
coiled has a way to like make Docker
images from content environment files
so you can like
you can either give it a Docker image or
you can give it like a Content
environment yaml spec
uh honestly this kind of sucks like I
actually really hate building Docker
images remotely somewhere it's like the
con to solve problem but now it's remote
so it's actually like even harder to
debug
um
uh and like takes a while it's like not
fun
um I showed you in the demo this package
sync thing uh which like just like
scrapes your local environment and tries
to recreate it this is actually also
very buggy this fails in lots of cases
but it's still way better than anything
I've seen before it's actually a really
smooth experience
uh kind of related to this uh we also do
like credential transfer like if you've
got credentials locally and you want to
access remote data we like see what
connectors you have we like make secure
tokens we ship those out to all the
workers in a safe secure way so you can
access data remotely we try very hard to
mimic the local experience at scale
without actually getting in the middle
that's an interesting dance that we try
to do
it works well for me
three I'll mentioned costs uh people
care about money as what I've learned
running a company
uh this is a display of I think our own
account uh running benchmarks on desk
and we are seeing is blue I think spot
availability and orange is on-demand
availability we have like weird policies
you can ask for responses which are like
three times cheaper uh but if there
aren't enough they will like give you on
demand and then we'll like if the spot
instances go away well like smoothly
exit them from the cluster right we
actually like handling this dance very
nicely actually is a significant
reduction in costs
we're doing this because we know coils
we know the cloud we also know dosk we
can do both of these things in tandem
quite well
there's one example I showed you all the
possible observability we can tell you
what you're doing
uh it's also free kind of uh we don't
really start charging you until we would
charge like a thousand dollars so about
10 000 CPU hours at that point per month
we start charging you
before then it's free we use all the pay
your cloud provider again we're just
like pressing buttons on your behalf we
can't make Amazon not pay not charge
here so those are the things I want to
talk about zooming back out
task is pretty easy deploying it is
sometimes easy but not always
as iceberg in here
um also in summary use desk it's great
also consider using a platform uh you
will eventually need the things that I
just talked about you could use coiled
you could use nabari you could do Saturn
you could use Q Hub you could use
kubeflow you could do something else but
like be aware you'll need these things
you got a data organ called IO finally
I'll mention there's some Das related
talks I want to call out uh there's
Apache Beam on desk from Alex yep
there's testing Big Data applications
from the few guys not in the room uh
there's scaling python uh from the Quan
site folks they like worked with desk on
a lot of banking applications
uh I'll be with that tutorial with David
and Natty on Thursday and right after
that there's a nabari tutorial if you
want to use their platform
thank you all for your attention I think
we've got about five minutes for
questions
[Music]
thank you
I also speak really quickly and so
there's no way everyone understood what
I said foreign
yeah so the question is can I run
non-python languages on dasc
infrastructure task runs python
functions on python objects those python
functions can call other languages
author running C to this plus rust Cuda
uh there are no good apis around dasc
from other languages though they're like
what's a Julia thing for a while but
maybe that's your question you feel like
C plus plus code put into python
function you're good to go
potato
Yeah you mentioned uh you cluster so it
works well when you have like like small
medium large configurations
can collaborate a little bit more on
that yes the question is I made this
claim that like kubernetes is not great
when you have a great variety of custom
requirements on your architecture
uh you can definitely get it to work and
like kubernetes folks in the room would
like Hound me a little bit
uh my experience is that like someone
asks for gpus great make a separate GPU
node pool if you like make labels and
you like annotate those labels the nodes
go to the right node pool in any like
ssds you make a different node pool with
those and leading to like you're
suddenly starting to like
mimic the hierarchy of the underlying
deployment infrastructure inside of
kubernetes with labels with paints with
tolerations with lots of different
kubernetes infrastructure to do that
will you find yourself architecting a
lot of that system inside of kubernetes
like kind of remodeling the world that's
my experience I found that to be painful
uh but there are other I think Carpenter
might be a thing that tries to get
through there's like various kubernetes
solutions to some of that as well
there's a question next you have a
question
I'm sorry can you speak up
um
how easy this update the model after
his appointment desk yeah so task mostly
is used to process data to train models
uh you can use it to do anything
um
it's not usually like a serving system
that's not a common a common application
um
um yeah but you can like you could very
easily write new python code and send
that to task
um dancing is a very low level tool that
allows you to run python code on
different computers
the way in which you use that is up to
you
um if you want is a good example I can
go to
a good way to get started with task is
to look at examples.das.org
and there are a bunch of fun examples
here and one you might be interested is
like uh using the desk to sort of back a
web server complicate computation and
this might be something similar to what
you're describing but I want to know
more I'm happy to chat afterwards
yeah maybe one more question yep
yep yeah
what's going on yeah so that's uh this
is not the right thing where would I go
you were talking about
let's just do it again how about that
yeah so uh yeah visibility transparency
Telemetry understanding what's going on
is super important right even in just
like the notebook experience right
knowing that you know
if I was just waiting here for two
minutes I would be nervous I would be
anxious I would be having negative
feelings but I know that they're
provisioning and I'm going to see in
like 10 seconds that they're going to
make progress and that's going to make
me happy
right super useful technologically we're
using a rich to do this so rich is a
great Library recommend looking at it a
textual is also very neat you should all
let go use textual and Rich
um but yeah I mean just like information
inside of user's eyes is good
that's probably a good point to stop on
thanks for the question
thank you welcome
[Applause]